are there specific techniques a director
can employ with an actor to get an
authentic performance yes don't you love
that answer yes
yeah there the I mean one way to the
director has to think about you know in
terms of authentic performance a little
bit of what that means that what that
really means is the character that
you're watching portrayed by the actor
the character is actually authentically
thinking feeling intending moving as the
character intends authentic authenticity
and the character means this is exactly
what's going on in the character not
something that's quote manufactured by
the actor more planned by the actor one
thing I talk about a lot and I'm very
serious about this that one of the
things that's most detrimental to a good
performance is an actor with a plan as
soon as actors says to me oh I know how
to play this scene I gotta read the
scene I know I know how to do this as
soon as I hear that I know I'm in
trouble because it's a plan because we
never in life plan how to play a scene
we as think as a character I as a
character you as a character going into
a moment as a person going in a moment
we have an idea of what we want to do
but we don't have a plan like an actor
could have a plan because an actor says
I know how I'm gonna play this line I
know how I'm gonna do this move and it
all becomes mechanical and may become a
performance that's brilliant and
stunning but it won't feel authentic
it'll feel like a performance so an
actually an authentic quote performance
really is not a performance at all
an authentic moment where the character
is an authentic moment where the
character and directors have to think
that way and so consequently directors
have to stop asking actors to give a
certain result I need more anger any
more rage I need more empathy any more
humility I may need more vulnerability
because that's a plan if the director
can think about igniting the character
and what the character is trying to do
in the situation
then the director will get and more
authentic performance it may not be
exactly the one he was hoping for or
aiming at but it will be authentic can
you tell us a story of any time you
corrected a director on directing an
actor and not the character Oh without
naming any more projects yeah that's
that's really I mean there are a lot of
them there are a lot of them there are a
lot of times I've been working with
directors now you're going to understand
that when I'm working with the director
if I'm consulting on a project not not
in a workshop workshop is one thing but
actually working on a project there's a
whole process that the director and I go
through which we call workshop in which
we bring actors in to actually do every
single scene in the movie these are not
the actors it'll be in the movie and
we're doing two or three things
simultaneously we're exploring the
characters were exploring the staging of
the scene and I'm also working with a
director on how he's working he or she
is working with the actors and this is
many times when I run into the result
directing and what I'll do is the
director may say to the act when doing a
scene that scenes going okay then that
director will say to the actor okay
let's do it again and she meaning the
character is more afraid here she I need
to see more fear and what I'll do right
at that moment I'll stop because this is
a workshop situation workshopping it's a
consult and I'll stop and I'll say to
the director I'm gonna do you a big
favor right now something that will
never happen unless I'm here to do it
for you I'm gonna ask the actor a
question he goes okay and I say to the
actor what did you just hear and what
did you just feel and the actor will say
oh well I heard that he wants more anger
and rage I said how do you feel and she
goes I'm pissed off and I'm confused and
I say to the director that's what you're
gonna get
is that what you want he goes uh no and
then I explained see what the pissed-off
and confused is that you've bypassed her
process you've told her just give me a
result figure out how to get there
rather than going back and talking to
the character rather than saying she is
more angry or she is more enraged at
this moment go back to the character and
build within the character the reason
for the rage build the rage and then
just send her into the scene so this is
the big difference between directing the
actor is giving a result and actually
telling the actor what you want telling
the activist the results you want and
even telling that to what you want them
to do on certain lines do this on this
line and the difference between that and
actually talking to the character and
igniting the character in a different
way and then send them into the scene
and chances are you'll get exactly what
you want how do you mean though well how
do you do that how would you build rage
if you're talking to the character
through the actor what what might you
say okay let's say it's a scene between
boyfriend/girlfriend which this one was
and they say you know it's with this
scene we and we all know this because we
read the scene it's going to end up in a
rape at the end of the scene a date rape
okay and she is very angry with him
because he's being very inappropriate
with her and he's been overly aggressive
so and this is where the director said
he wanted more anger and he's thinking
appropriately I need that anger to get
him angry enough to stimulate the rape
okay but the thing is why is she angry
to be to begin with no I could just say
- I need more anger out of her but I can
go back to the character her name is
Susan I and I could say and I go back to
Susan I said Susan why are you on this
date now and she'll answer the question
what am i I said do you really want to
be with him but she's an item and I can
start to question what's going on inside
the character at that moment why she's
resenting him why she doesn't want to be
on the date why this is bringing up some
kind of fears and discomfort within her
and I'm just I'm just building that
actually what's going on in the carrot
I'm just igniting that and I say okay
let's do the scene again and now she
goes into the scene with all these
feelings genuinely inside her not
manufactured they're genuinely in there
and she goes on the scene and you'll get
it you'll get what you want in other
words it's I know what the result is I
want what's gonna cause that within the
character for that to happen I have to
ignite that I don't have to ask for the
result I have to ignite what causes the
result the cause not the effect okay so
you're egging Susan on you're saying
you're actually giving examples saying
he's he's he's being too rough with you
he's being disrespectful you're almost
throwing out your thing yes and no
Darren I'm not egging her on
I would never do that because it said
all this is all done with questions
that's why it's called interrogation I
would say how do you feel about him
right now I haven't feel fine well why
are you with him I don't do you want to
be with him no I said then why don't you
leave now I'm still asking her a
question and I'm forcing her to question
herself did generate rather than me I'm
not I'm not I'm not attaching something
to her I'm stimulating something from
within her and I stalked us and I can
stimulate the emotions that come on with
whatever this discomfort is or this this
these feelings that she's having inside
and now what's happened is the actress
will just call her Joan the actress Joan
is gone Susan is so ignited because I'm
just interrogating Susan interrogating
Susan and she's so ignited I said going
to the scene Joe and the actress is
basically and this is what a lot of the
actors say when they work this way it
goes I'm just gonna watch and see what
Susan does she they have no control they
have no control over the carrot that our
character totally takes control so
that's that's the different you know in
working with actors and this is the
problem that this is what I deal with
all the time when I'm consulting I'm
dealing with it when I'm teaching
directors how to work this is what
Michael saw at the at the DGA you
remember all that
you